because when people come to me and say
how many properties have you got none I
would not advise that there's three
things you should do instead or as well
as number one hey what's up my name's
Samuel Leeds and if you watch my videos
and if you've been in property for a
while you'll probably know about
serviced accommodation serviced
accommodation is something that I do
it's in it that I've been advocating for
years many of my students do it and what
that means is instead of renting out a
property the normal way I always want to
create extra cash flow so instead of
renting a house out the normal way you
can do other things like split up and
rent it out by the room as a HML or
renting out as service the combination
now here's the problem in London there's
a 90-day rule which says that you cannot
rent a property out for more than 90
days and that's not consecutive days
that's 90 days per year you cannot do
that within Greater London and a lot of
people ask me about this they say Samuel
what about the 90-day rule in London you
know as if it's like the biggest thing
in the world so let me just explain my
opinion on the 90-day rule it's really
obvious what it is you cannot repeat
cannot and a lot of people do it anyway
and they just say you know what you know
what's the saying they say forgiveness
is better than permission I'll just do
it and if we get caught then I'll just
stop or they have different accounts
with different channel managers you know
and they just do it anyway I would not
advise that or certainly wouldn't
advocate to do that I know a lot of
people do do it because I think that you
can make enough money without having to
break the law sometimes you've got to
bend the rules a little bit don't break
the law so don't do that there's three
things you should do instead or as well
as number one is you've got to check you
just change the use so if you've got a
flat in London and you want to rent it
out on air B&B and you can't because
it's in London and you can't do it for
more than 90 days in the year and you're
like man I really want to do it more
than 90 days I really want this property
I want its purpose to be serviced
accommodation property I want this
property long term I want to list it on
Airbnb I'm bugging calm I want it to a
function as a hotel if you want to do
that in London then you need to
change the use you need to go to the
council change it from a c3 which you'll
probably be most properties you know by
to that properties are on a c3 what that
means is that's the purpose of the
property so every property has a purpose
has a function if it's a farm commercial
properties shop or a at a general house
or a guest house a hotel a serviced
accommodation property so if you change
the use from c3 to c1 and you'll need to
do this it will cost money and it will
take time I'm not it won't cost like
thousands and thousands but it will cost
money people take time and you can just
change the use contact your counsel and
see if they'll be able to do that for
you and I wouldn't recommend doing this
on a property that you're just
controlling so don't take on a rent to
rent and then try and change the use
because it's the amount of hassle that's
involved in it when you don't even own
the property it's probably not worth it
but if you own it and it's in Greater
London and you want to run it as a guest
house or as a like a home self-service
accommodation change the use that's
option number one option number two is
you just rent it out for 90 days
and a lot of people are doing this you
know what's shocking in Greater London
7% and this is according to the
Telegraph 7% of properties in Greater
London that's in central London 7% of
those properties are on Airbnb I'm
booking calm at some point throughout
the year that's staggeringly high that
means you're walking through the main
streets of London looking at all the
houses the apartments seven percent of
them throughout the year or on air B&B
no calm at some point in that year but
what a lot of people are doing is
they'll rent out for 90 days bang bang
bang bang bang bang bank in peak periods
might be the summer might be over
Christmas New Year period get loads of
money and then for the rest of the year
that went to an AST contract short
contract AST and then they'll move the
person at and then bang do it again for
90 days you can do that a lot of people
do that it's completely legal it's
completely aboveboard and it's a way of
just maximizing the rent taking
advantage of being able to do that in
central London you can get a lot of
rounds doing this in central London but
you're not breaking the law so that's
option number two obviously number three
and probably this will be for you if
you're because when people come to me
and there's a
so how many properties have you got none
how long you been in the game I've just
got started but they're going on but
what about the rule in London how's
about just moves slightly outside of
London Dec like why focus on an area
where it doesn't work it's like the same
people that say these options don't work
in Scotland well do it in Middlesbrough
then like why focus on what doesn't work
in a particular area so the people that
say to me you know oh it doesn't work in
London it's like we'll just do it in
Watford or st. Albans or Oxford like I
live in beckons field my property that
I'm in right now is a company let like
and and there's no rules just outside
London the this rule the 90-day rule
only applies for Greater London that's
essential and then just move slightly
outside Cambridge you can kill it in
Cambridge doing serviced accommodation
you can rent properties and then put
them on air B&B in bomb.com as long as
that you're not breaking the mortgage
terms or that all of the head lease and
as long as have permission from the
landlord you can get really wealthy
doing that why focus on the area where
it doesn't work or there's a cap move
area so but if you can't move area
because if you own the property then do
one of the two things either just went
out for 90 days or change the use of the
property with the count still get
planning permission to it from c3
or whatever it is to a c1 those are your
three options hope you found that video
helpful please do summation the like
button also please do subscribe to the
channel turn the notification bow on so
you never miss a video if you want to
see more about service accommodation and
how you can make money in rent Ament and
serviced accommodation do that right
here if you want to hear a story of
someone that's making thousands of
pounds a month starting from nothing
in rent to serviced accommodation
strategy you can watch that story video
right here and if you'd like to see the
same and you want to get trained and you
want to become successful in property
comment down to the property investors
crash course you can do that right over
here get booked on watch the videos
subscribe and I'll see you next time